editing videos for YouTube channels
influencers business marketing
strategies and social media posts have
become common for many users we have
spent a lot of time editing and
innovating videos for our posts yet what
if I told you if we can use AI based
video editing tools to create videos
that look more professional yes there
are multiple websites precisely designed
for our convenience but choosing the
right AI website for editing your videos
easily for your business is a tough task
hi everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and get ready to take a
look into some of the best AI websites
for video editors in 2023 but before we
begin if you like watching similar
videos subscribe to Simply launch
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from us to begin
with let's take a look at the advantages
of using AI websites for video editing
it provides us with hundreds of filters
effects and templates for editing our
videos it is easier to handle the
resources and set them for the final
result these websites apply computer
algorithms to suggest the video's best
design and editing steps tools and
functions on the website are completely
easy to use affordable and don't need
prior knowledge on the topic now if you
want to step into video editing for
professional or personal use keep
watching the video till the end where we
will look at the top 10 AI websites for
video editors in 2023 so without further
Ado at number 10 on the list we have
vedia vedia is an AI based website that
allows users to create and publish high
quality videos for monetizing our
content like Ott CTV and dooh for
desktops and smartphones this website is
is great for handling extensive content
data and suggesting the relevant
features best for the video
automatically designing personalizing
and Publishing the video are some of the
best features of pedia at number nine we
have Runway ml this website applies deep
learning techniques to design and create
Innovative visual effects and transition
features for the videos tools available
on the side can easily handle masking
adding VFX and suggesting color and tone
correction for the content this website
services are free or for a premium
account at 30 to 100 dollars per month
at number eight we have rephrase
rephrase dot AI is a unique video editor
that allows you to edit the video by
providing the content business based
editors use rephrase.ai to save money
that is invested or used to hire an
entire our team the features and
rephrase.ai provide the editors with a
realistic video by just providing the
transcript and these features are
available to us at a price of 25 to 500
dollars per month at number 7 we have
magesto Magisto AI website is an AI
video designing editing and marketing
platform for online businesses the AI
provides us with a three-step video
creating function first upload photos
related to the business second select
the video designing and editing template
along with the sound effect for the
video third and the final step the a AI
will Design and edit the video for us
which is available at a price of 5 to 35
dollars per month at number six we have
wisecut wisecut ai is a unique editing
platform that uses Ai and voice
recognition features to edit the videos
it provides a way to increase the
effectiveness of the features and
provides a much more efficient final
result the voice feature of AI
automatically changes the depth tone and
speech of the provided script according
to the scene in the video at a price of
57 per month at number 5 we have raw
shots the raw shot AI tool uses article
and Text data and Designs them into
videos with the assistance of high spec
AI technology the AI identifies keywords
from the input data and creates a scene
related to it in seconds but no doubt
the Minor Details can be done by manual
editing with the service is priced at 39
to 59 dollars per month at number four
we have Avenue
avio.ei is a high quality video editing
tool that allows you to create videos
through content it allows you to choose
from numerous high quality images and
music tracks from Shutterstock it also
provides features like reframing
interpolating frames and transition
effects at a price of 9 to 99 dollars
per month
this for the top seven and now we step
into the top three websites you've been
waiting for at number three we have
Lumen 5. lumen5. AI allows us to create
video content with our ideas and add
interactive music to the mix the AI uses
techniques to design a layout for the
content it uses the major keywords
mentioned to search for images and
relevant data for creating the video
with the files import function to choose
more personalized options at number 2 we
have comma the comma.ar uses Cloud
Computing Services to manage and design
large project content with the best
performing tools and services following
the provided price it also provides
basic features like resizing captioning
and reframing the video with the
subtitle function to add over 60
languages to choose from at a price of
two to ten dollars per month at number
one we have V Dot IO we dot AI uses
machine learning techniques to customize
the video with clear color Choice
correct font interactive animation video
transition effect and template design it
uses the given context to search for a
relevant high quality image media
content music and visual effects and
also it provides recording options and
AI generated voiceover for the video it
is available to us at a price of 4 to 20
dollars per month and with this we have
completed our session on the top 10 AI
websites for video editors for 2023.
what was your favorite video editing AI
website in the list or should you feel
that we must start on any of the
important AI based video editing
websites then do let us know in the
comment section below and in case if you
have any queries or if you want to share
your views then please type them down in
the comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here